well hello that sorry I was just busy
respecting women
my name is nice guy PewDiePie and I've
collected millions of followers just
like yourself were just that nice guys
we spend most of my days respecting
women and putting them first thinking
how can we be better how can we be less
horrible demons the creatures of the
night join me as we will now go through
some of the nicest guys on the internet
just like me and just like you or at
least if you're not yet you could become
a nice guy let's check out the nice guy
subreddit and celebrate some of the
nicest people on the planet nice guys
operator what is your emergency please
help some men broke into my home not all
men are like that
I wouldn't do that as a fellow nice guy
myself I would never break up into
another woman's home if there was a man
in there perhaps I would consider it but
I would make sure the woman was feeling
safe cuz I'm a nice guy Peter pie and if
you're a nice guy as well you would
understand I hate the friendzone you
make a girl chocolate milk and she won't
have sex with you unbelievable what's
the point I make this big chocolate I
gave you my everything I'm making
chocolate mac why don't you love me I'm
such a nice guy
why Lisa why Lisa please talk to me
please
why all these women pick all these
douche bags
if they only knew what a nice guy I am
you're scaring me
graffiti I saw in Melbourne today how
nice guys think sex works times are
respected women
this is lush sex come on at least credit
crib it the man properly we look so much
like a couple here ha ha ha ha a couple
of besties
oh no everyone a moment of silent for
this man that's gonna that's gonna
[ __ ] sting you know ever I'm just
gonna see that be like god damn that
[ __ ] get cut the [ __ ] out me me I'd
like to become a citizen of Finland oh
nice I guess back in line why nice guys
finish last
good job hey hey abut this Hey are you
finished no I am Swedish ah
yes I am proud virgin because unlike you
sexually activated savages I would never
ever
put Amy genitals anywhere near you it's
a shame with those dick sucking lips -
you had a lot of potential yeah I wish
some girl could see past my looks and
just like me for who I am I love you
Robert yes but you're ugly it's always
like nice guys as always this guy's
going for girls out of their league I
think that's the issue I mean no they
are nice guys because in their heart
they have good intention okay they're
not some sexually charged savages my you
saved me okay thank you here is a kiss I
crossed a train full of monsters my
princess
pick up your paper I actually said this
when I played the latest Super Mario cuz
you do so much [ __ ] to save her right
I'm like she better fish you better put
out probably shouldn't have that in ha
what are they supposed to mean my god
I'm not your average nice game cuz I can
give you orgasm you'll never forget
doubt it
I don't lie to women law so you only
lied to me oh I don't believe in
antiquated concept of dating
relationship and married after seeing
your profile I have changed my mind good
thing yeah what a great coincidence he
changed his mind running right after he
got rejected that's good they look that
great for everyone
hello I am staying nice to meet you
you're so attractive to me and I love
your cute face 20 minutes later stuck-up
[ __ ] I can deliver you mainly wait wait
a minute
I I leave me a nice guy I may be a nice
guy named Stan but he
you make me wait twenty minutes then my
theory will be around really step on you
you stack up B word it's stupid when
girls say they can't find a guy yet they
ignore me
it's like saying you're hungry when
there's a hot dog on the ground that's a
good tweet why would anyone drink or do
drugs I get high off respecting women me
too and anyone that's a nice guy can
relate it's one of the most joyous
adventures you can go on it's a very
rewarding I have a boyfriend that's nice
but I'm not interested sorry your ass
every girl a goalie no need to be rude
why me you are rude no me how am i rude
every girls are the same how come you
all lie cheat not give me okay what the
[ __ ] a good guy a chance
built for this man you gotta give the
good man a chance a good guy deserves
chance I already have a boyfriend I hope
you cheat on you and you deserve but
that you ugly hope you die
okay good bad hope you dick I think men
should post not me to show that most of
us are good men who would never assault
or abuse women yet love
someone actually thought this oh my god
hashtag not me not me I'm a nice guy
hey Ana what's their English homework
nope
thank you so much no problem dude sir
what's up filling out college
applications cool I'm watching the flesh
you there yes sorry I was focused on my
work can we talk about something okay
dude do you even want to talk I can talk
let's talk about movies what's your
favorite movie you like scary more ha ha
let me add let me think I like guardians
of the galaxy if I didn't know better I
think you were trying to impress me what
everyone knows I love superheroes lots
of people like them well it's cool that
we have this in common
we actually are pretty similar if you
think about it and you made it me no why
would I be mad at you oh well you didn't
respond so I just assumed I'm sorry no
it's all good I'm just - what right now
well when you aren't busy would you like
to come date with me and treat you nice
didn't take you to movie not sure how
much the boyfriend would like that well
you don't have to be so rude
[Music]
you're been short with me these atanga
with oh my god I can't Jesus Christ it's
tough being a nice guy
we got a we got a short fuse I respected
women three times today let me smash
it's not how it works yes yes eres Oh
era is a cute name
maybe if I stay she'll see my dedication
to her and and will go out with me
the hurricane my boyfriend what a jerk
milady surely deserves faded I would
always treat you with respect
[Laughter]
[Music]
damn me and my for I am just too nice
what were you bullied for it for being
shy and uncomfortable around boys tatata
how can I make this about me let's see I
agree Iceman can be literal [ __ ] but
but got adding that I'm not an [ __ ]
there are so lovely and generous
gentlemen like me out there somewhere if
you're an actual nice person you
shouldn't have to try so hard to let
everyone else know that you're a nice
person you should just be a nice person
just like me leave a like if you're a
nice guy no matter who you are if you're
a nice guy this has been your host nice
guy Peter Pienaar excuse me while I keep
on respecting women everyday bro
squat pay men
you like scary movies huh what's your
favorite scary movie
[Music]